if you want to get really good at
anything it's just copy it as closely as
possible a lot of designers don't do
this because this kind of work is boring
it's technical it's tedious but i gotta
tell you that work paid off back in the
day there was no bigger designer than
david carson he was the king of all
design he'd walk in the room and girls
would swoon guys would faint and they
admired him from afar and they copied
his aesthetic what they didn't
understand didn't copy his structure and
his thinking but what i would do is i
would open up these booklets and with
pen and ruler just draw over it so i can
see like the connections when i started
drawing grid lines over everything he
did i got a very strong sense that this
man understands grid and design these
things were not just happening by
accident so i felt like i discovered
some kind of secret key just by doing
that so that's what i would do copywork
is underutilized and underrated as
something that can really be
instrumental in you learning at some
point you move away from that but in the
very early stages copywork is great do
your best to copy the work as if your
forger do that first